الرئيس الصيني شيء جنب بنك يبداوا اليوم
زياره الرسميه لسعوديه تستمر حتى الجمعه
الحرس الثوري الايراني بتصرف بشكل غير امن
وغير مهني في مضيقهم
[تصفيق]
وفي انجاز عربي
يتاهل الى دور الثمانيه في كاس العالم
[موسيقى]
اسعد الله صباحكم بكل خير واهلا بكم
من العربيه
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه
الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز
في قمه سعوديه صينيه
ومن المقرر ان تشهد القمه السعوديه صينيه
توقيع اتفاقيه مبدئيا بين البلدين ب 110
مليارات ريال او ما يعادل نحو 30 مليار
دولار وفقا لوكاله الانباء السعوديه
وذكرت الوكاله ان عدد الاتفاقات سيصل الى
20 اضافه لتوقيع وثيقه شراكه الاستراتيجيه
بين السعوديه والصين وكذلك خطه بين رؤيه
المملكه 2030 ومبادره الحزام والطريق
الجيش الامريكيه البحريه على الحاره
[موسيقى]
سياسيه قال سيره الجمهوريهم في تصريحاته
خاصه للعربيه حول التظاهرات في ايران انه
يجب عزل ايران اكثر واخضر قضيه الى الامم
المتحده ومقاضات طهران على جميع الاصايده
هو جرائم حرب ضد الناس قائلا ان شعب
الايراني يجب ان يسمع صوتنا قدر الامكان
حق الايرانيين في المطالبه بتغيير وعدم
تناقض معتبرا ان اسوء شيء يمكن ان تفعله
اداره بيضا هو الدخول في مفاوضات نوويه مع
النظام الايراني لان هذا النظام يقتل شعبه
وفقه تعبيره
وكده الامريكيه الغاء شرطه الاخلاق يظهر
بعض الدلائل على ان النظام الايراني
ستفعل كل ما في وسعها لعزل النظام
الايراني
حتى يتمكنوا من الاستمرار في رداء ايران
توضح الاداره الامريكيه اننا لن نتفاوضا
مع ايران مضيفا ان ذلك سيرسل رساله دعم
الى المحتاجين الايرانيين والاشخاص الذين
يحاولون الدفاع عن بعض الشعور بالحريه
وشهدت مختلف المدن الايرانيه امس اضرابات
لليوم الثاني على التوالي حيث اغلقت
المحاله التجاريه والشركات كما اضرب نحو
500 من عمال العقود العاملين في شركه
خزانات بتروكيماويات في جنوب غرب ايران في
حضور ذلك تواصلت تظاهرات في عدد من المدن
الايرانيه لاسيه من العاصمه طهران ومحافظه
خراسان وفارس ومشهد شمال شرق ايران
وحشتيني
[موسيقى]
تنظر
الى الامتصاص غضب المحتاجين والالتفاف على
مطالب
التظاهرات تتواصل وسلطات الايرانيه ترد
تصعيد يفاجئ النظام الباحث عن مخرج ولو
بكي نفسه
مجبرا ينظر النظام في امكانيه تخفيف بعض
القيود على النساء وفق ما ذاكرته صحيفه
اشارت الى ان مسؤولين ايرانيين بصدد وضع
اللمسات الاخيره على خطط لاصلاح انفاذ
القوانين المتعلقه بملابس النساء
كثيره مطروحه حول تلك توجهات لا سيما في
مدى جديه النظام على التغيير والى اين
يمكن ان يذهب لا تفاصيل حول الاصلاحات
المجمعه غير انما رشا حيشي بتغليظ
الغرامات الماليه والتخفيف من الاحتجاز
والاستجواب
محاولات تبدو حظوظ نجاحها على الارض غير
مضمونه فالاحتجاجات مستمره والاضطرابات
تتوالى حتى ان القرار الاخير بحل شرطه
الاخلاق لم يكن كافيا ولا مقنعا
للمتظاهرين
توجههم مشكوك فيه خصوصا في ما يمس اسس
عقائديه يقوم عليها النظام اصلا وهو ما
بدا واضحا في كلام الرئيس الايراني اسس
الجمهوريه راسخه في الدستور اما المرونه
في وسائل تطبيقه كما يقول وهي وسائل لا
يثق بها المحتجون اساسا
[موسيقى]
حقق المنتخب المغربي اجازه تاريخيا لدور
الثمانيه من المونديال قطر بعد فوزه على
المنتخب الاسباني بركلات الترجيح وبذلك
يكون المغرب اول منتخب عربي يتاهلوا لهذه
المرحله المتقدمه كاس العالم
[تصفيق]
الله
احتفالات بفوز المنتخب المغربي وصلت حتى
الى اسبانيا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
المبعوث الامريكيه تهم الحوثيين بعدم
الالتزام بالهدنه ويؤكد
تفهمهم او تلقيهم الدعم والتمويل من ايران
اهلا بكم من جديد حمل المبعوث الامريكي
الى اليمن
في عمليه السياسيه
اذا ابسط الشروط الاتفاق من الاتفاقات
السابقه فتح الطرقان الى ثالث اكبر مدينه
في اليمن تعز والتي كانت محاصر مدعمه 2015
والان في الاسابيع عقيل الماضي اطلاق
الحوثيون سلسله من الهجمات تهدد الملاحات
الدوليه بينما يسعون لقطع تدفق الحر
للوقود وحرمان الحكومه اليمنيه من الارباح
من خلال فعل ذلك الحوثيين يحرمون اليمنيين
من المرتبات الضروريه والخدمات
والتنميه التي تدفعها الحكم اليمني بهذه
الارباح نحنا
حرج انه حافظ على الزخمه ايجابي
والمكتسبات ابريل وهذا يعني الهجمات
الحوثيين الاخيره وزياده مطالبات انها
بعمليه سياسيه يقودها اليمنيون
بعض اكثر من سته سنوات من التحقيقات
والبراجعات وتنسيق قضايا محاكم الارهاب
الفرنسيه والبلجيكيه انطلقت في بروكسل
محاكمه تفجيرات مطار ومترو بروكسل العامه
دخلت محاكمه التفجيرات مطار وميترو بروكسل
في الثاني والعشرين من شهر مارس لعام 2016
جوهره القضيه مع انطلاق تلاوه بيان
الاتهامات والادله في حق المتهمين العشره
في حضور ممثلين اكثر من 900 و40 من
الضحايا وذويهم واصحاب بالحق المدني
موفقه نحو الحقيقه القضائي وسيقول اعضاء
هيئه المحلفين بعد اشهر كلمتهم بشان
المتهمين
ان هم وابنبون ام ابرياء في قفص الاتهام
تسعه من بينهم محمد عبريني صاحب القبعه
الذي تخلى عن حقيبته المفخخه في مطار
بروكسل تاركا وراءه الدماره والهلعه
والقتل الذي احدثه تفجير حقيبتي
الانتحاريين ابراهيم البكراوي ونجيم
العشراوي صباح يوم الثلاثاء 22 من شهر
مارس في الاثنين كان خالد البكراوي قد فجر
حقيبته في العربه الثانيه من متر محطه
البيك وسط العاصمه خمسه من المتهمين
حكم عليهم بالسجن
عده من موعد التفجيرات باريس
مقاطعه المحكمه احتجاجا على ما وصفوه بمع
كامل مهينه من قبل قوات الامن رئيسه
المحكمه القت المسؤوليه على وزير الداخليه
[موسيقى]
بوقف المعامله المهينه مثل انحناء المتهم
عاريا امام رجال الامن والموسيقى الصاخبه
هذه الممارسات لا علاقه لها بالمقتضيات
الامنيه هذا السلوك تواصل حتى اليوم
المتهمون عشره تسعه في قفص الاتهام
والمتهم العاشر اسامه عطار متغيب واشتبه
في انه كان المشرف الاول على تفجيرات
باريس وبروكسيل انطلاقا من دير الزهور
تردد انه قتل في غارته مسيره في العام
2017 في سوريا في رساله صوتيه
من شهر مارس العام 2016 يقول الانتحاريان
نجيم العشراوي وابراهيم البكراوي الى
اسامه عطار المكنى ابو احمد العراقي
والموجود ان ذلك في سوريا يقولون
البيجو بيتحرك المجموعه من دون تاخر يعني
افراد المجموعه اصبحوا محاصرين ويفتقدون
مجرد السكن الامن وكانت تحركم في اليوم
الموالي صباح الثلاثاء الاسود
الانتهاكات المستمرين للمعاهدات سيفتح
سيادتها هذه الجزر للنقاش ويجبروا تركيا
على الدفاع عن حقوقها مشيرا الى انها يجب
ان تظلم الزراعه سلاح بما يتماشى مع
المعاهدات الدوله
بين النواب داخل البرلمان مع مناقشه
الميزانيه العامه للعام المقبل وفقا
للتقرير او تقارير تركيا
الى مصر
بحث وزير الخارجيه الاردنيه
الملك عبد الله الثاني ورئيس الوزراء
العراقي محمد شيعه سوداني في عمان الشهر
الماضي
القضايا العربيه
ذكر الرسول في حكومه طالبان انه سيسمح
للفتيات الافغانيات في اجراء امتحانات
التخرج من المدارس الثانويه بالرغم من
منعهم من فصول الدراسه منذ سيطره طالبان
على البلاد
وثيقتين من وزاره التعليم طالبان يطبق
القرار على 31 ولايه افغانيه من اصل 34
قبل بدء عطله دراسه الشتويه اواخره
لقطات المصوره بطائره من دون طيار في سماء
العاصمه الهنديه نيودلهي كثافه الضباب
الدخاني وتفاقم التلوث مع موجه البرد التي
تشهدها البلاد ويعاني سكانه نيودلهي
وضواحيها من تلوث الهواء كل شتاء وموجه
غبار البناء وانبعثره المركبات والدخان
خاصه في ولايتي البنجاب وهاريانا
المجاورتين
[موسيقى]
وفي نهايه النشر هذا التذكير بها براس
العالم
يه تستمر حتى الجمعه
الجيش
في كاس العالم
نهايه النشره الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]